[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis
weltreise gibt es ein richtig cooles er
wir werden ein komplettes er im glas
machen das besteht aus drei komponenten
einmal unten die fruchtige füllung dann
die creme schicht und obendrauf das
krampe die drei komponenten werde ich
jetzt nacheinander herstellen ich
brauche folgende zutaten fürs crumble
verwende ich 100 gramm butter 100 g
zucker 200 gramm mehl zimt und salz für
die frucht füllung verwende ich ein
bisschen zitronensaft zwei entspannte
zwetschgen und auch ein bisschen zucker
und für die creme verwende ich 250 gramm
quark 250 gramm frischkäse leid etwas
vanille extrakt zitronensaft und kokos
blüten zucker nämlich erst die weiche
butter die gebe ich jetzt in der
rührschüssel und ihr braucht jetzt hier
auch gar keine kirchen dann habe ich
hier etwas dinkelmehl ihr könnt auch
normales weizenmehl verwenden oder auch
ein bisschen vollkommen mail und hat
halt mission zum beispiel ich habe ich
jetzt den zucker da habe ich jetzt kokos
blüten zucker aber auch hier geht
normaler zucker oder auch brauner
zukunft und am besten schmeckt dir
einfach mal ab wie süßes dann wird aber
von der menge her passt so ganz genau
denn die frucht füllung die wird ein
bisschen säuerlicher und dafür werden
die crumble ein bisschen süße dann etwas
salz nimmt jetzt die zutaten und kurz
miteinander verbinden
erst ein bisschen im löffel und dann
gerne auch mit der hand
[Musik]
durch den kokons bilden zucker haben die
streusel eine richtig tolle farbe wenn
die streusel dann soweit sind werden sie
jetzt auf einem blech verteilt
[Musik]
jetzt können die streusel schon im
vorgeheizten backofen gebacken werden
und ich fühle mich schon mal uns
ausgekontert die zwetschgen habe ich
jetzt nur entsteint wenn gerade keine
sprints saison ist dann könnt ihr
natürlich auch einfach nur äpfel nehmen
oder äpfeln birnen
aber es gibt zum beispiel auch
zwetschgen aus dem tiefkühlfach ein
bisschen auch recht gut die sind
meistens sogar schon direkt in stein und
spart euch die arbeit und ihr habt sie
immerfort und meine mama gemacht so
reimer sowie hatten die friert sie sich
dann selber ein und dann hat sie halt
auch immer zwetschge es sollte ab wird
das alles kennt jetzt jeder nehmen dann
abgelehnt kerner oder eben viertel
unternimmt kamen die beides aber mit
apfel entkernt entsteht halt immer so
ein durch cook noch ja und dann den
apfel und die zweitstimme einfach bis
klein schneiden und mit zitronensaft und
zucker vermischen
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich das kompott ein
bisschen einkochen ich lasse es jetzt
auf kochen auf höchster stufe stellt den
herd dann runter auf mittlere stufe und
dann darf so 10 minuten köcheln
und wer möchte kann jetzt ja noch
rosinen zufügen ein bisschen zwetschgen
blick höher oder andere augen wie der
vanilleschote zum beispiel
aber ich gebe später die wanne der zu
kriegen dazu nach der hälfte der
backzeit werden die streusel gewendet so
dass der auf beiden seiten schön braun
werden und wer möchte kann zwei minuten
vor ende der backzeit noch gehackte
mandeln oder gestiftete wandeln zufügen
jetzt höre ich schon mal die creme
zusammen ihr könnt jetzt hier auch eine
maske ab ohne sahne creme machen oder
wie ich so endete das leichtere variante
mit quark und frischkäse und dafür gebe
ich jetzt auch alle zutaten einfach hier
in die rührschüssel dann wieder ein
bisschen und kokos blüten zucker da
schmeckt ein bisschen karamell iga und
neunziger und gibt den gerichten immer
noch schöne farbe
[Musik]
und gern noch ein bisschen vanille
extrakt dazu richtig schön kein ich
jetzt stelle ich die creme noch in den
kühlschrank freunde sind auch gleich
fertig und kommen aus dem backofen und
das kompott werde ich jetzt auch zum
abkühlen beiseite stellen
[Musik]
die zwetschgen apfel masse habe ich
bereits in gläser eingeführt und die ist
jetzt wirklich gut durch gekühlt die
creme fühle ich jetzt noch in einen
spritzbeutel so mache ich dann zu viel
zauberei
beim einfüllen dann immer wenn ich das
manchmal extrem viel sonne rein
eigentlich sollte ich mir das abgewöhnt
aber egal wann wir sind jetzt acht
gläser entstanden hier fühle ich jetzt
gleich im anschluss wird jetzt einfach
von der creme sondern bisschen was drauf
geben und auch gar nicht so viel damit
einfach nicht so mächtig wird gerade mit
den mandeln hätte ich echt ein hit und
schon ist das dessert fertig richtig gut
und im prinzip könnt ihr die komponenten
alle richtig gut vorbereiten
wenn ihr zum beispiel sowieso gerne
kompott einkocht könnt ihr euer
selbstgemachtes kopf ort verwenden die
krampe sind auch super schnell
hergestellt und dann habt ihr in
windeseile ein richtig schönes
eigentlich so thierfelder erst konkret
damit gesamte einrichtung weihnachten
kann das dann noch winterlich abwandeln
mit zimt und nelken zum beispiel
richtig gut und vor allem durch den
quark und den light frischkäse wirklich
gar nicht schwer und nach dem essen es
ich sowas echt mal gerne murat ist
leider nicht da zum probieren aber ich
suche jetzt gleich noch im haus ein paar
handwerker ich glaube da finde ich
gleich noch welche die dass der sehr
gerne probieren möchten falls es mal
probieren wollte dann geht auf salehs -
blog.de war steht noch einmal das genaue
rezept ich wünsche euch viel spaß und
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
ich möchte einen kuchen backen und darf
es jetzt hier im wald und sind auf der
suche nach zutaten die ich für den
kuchen verwenden kann es kraft kostet
alles nichts kelly zauber deine wald
worte aussprechen baumrinde und
bucheckern
das hat mich schon verwundert dass man
da mehr draus machen kann da schätzt man
die torte ein bisschen anders
sie ist einfach wertvoll
einfach herrlich sonntag 16 uhr bei vox
[Musik]